okay welcome alex mackie and thank you
for being part of
ndc melbourne
thanks very much guys oh you're welcome
so um are you going to talk about
rockets or
uh we're not going to be talking about
rockets well maybe we will a little bit
very good now i know you're going to
talk about digital twins because that's
what it says in the title
um this is one of the things that i
haven't actually played with so i'm kind
of keen to see
what the possibilities are i know it's
iot and i know it's
that sort of world of things on azure
but other than that i have no idea
yeah now for those of you planning to
use this to go and stretch around and
take a break
please please stick around i'll tell you
why i think this is going to be
interesting and applicable to a lot of
people
it is one of those sort of maybe niche
services that's a little bit rarer but
let me tell you uh all about it
so um welcome to introduction to digital
twins
and the azure digital twin platform
my name is alex mackey everything i'm
going to show you today i'll put up at
my website
simpleisbest.com so you can go and get
this stuff later
i work as a tech lead for an
organization called willow
at willow we're very much focused on
digital twins um
and for for the building systems and
critical infrastructure
so if i do my job correctly what are you
gonna learn in the next 45 minutes or so
well we're going to start off by talking
what exactly is a digital twin in the
first place
how are digital twins been used in the
real world
where did these things come from in the
first place and then we're going to look
at the fundamentals of the azure digital
twin platform so you can go and
implement this stuff yourself
so before you nip off for lunch one
thing i do want to mention
is that the global twin market is
massive now
those crazy analysts and some of them
are a bit crazy have estimated this is
an
area that's going to be growing to 17.4
billion us dollars by 2024.
i think because of the size of this
there's a reasonable likelihood
that if you're a developer or involved
in some aspect of software engineering
at some point you might quite likely
will touch a digital twin
project so
what exactly is a digital twin anyway
well simply put a digital twin can be
thought of as a virtual representation
of a real-world item or process
let's take a simple example we've got a
cog
and this cog is equipped with a number
of sensors maybe they measure the
revolutions of this cog
and they send this data into some kind
of digital twin system
or platform and on this platform we
create a virtual representation of this
cog
now linking these two things you'll find
in the literature this is referred to as
a fred which i think is kind of a nice
analogy
given these two things are inextricably
linked
now an important thing i want to get
across is you don't necessarily need to
use digital twins to
model things like cogs or engineering or
engines which is often a lot of examples
you see these could be processes
as well and i'm going to show you a few
examples of how this has been
employed at the moment
let's start off with a simple example of
a digital twin
now let's take any typical large
building this building
has several um probably 100 different
systems operating inside of it
it's got electricity it's got water it's
got heating there's various security
systems
um all sorts of things going on there
we'll take one of these um pretty much
every building will be or hopefully will
be equipped with some kind of air
conditioning unit
on the top there now this air
could have a number of sensors on it and
this sensor
is providing various different details
and on a typical one we might be able to
pull out maybe the temperature
the humidity uh the air quality fan rpms
maybe even when this unit was last
serviced
now this data could all be fed into
another system
where the building manager could see
what's going on with this air
conditioning unit
what temperatures is it at the moment
when was the last time it's been
inspected and so on
now when i started working with digital
twins one of the first questions i had
were are digital twins just a form of
dashboard
well i think there's more to it than
that and let me tell you more
so with all of these type of device
devices there's an enormous amount of
data they could be giving us
and it's almost too much to do anything
useful with there could be data from
literally hundreds or thousands of
different sources in a typical large
building
and one of the things that i think
digital twins enable us to do is to go
and take this data
we'll go and process it blend it get all
the good stuff out
and then we can start drawing insights
which we can actually do something with
rather than actually just dealing with a
large blob of data that's no good for
anyone
krichner ettel just means there's a
number of people involved
in this study i don't know how they
decide who's the main one i like to
think they fight it out highlander style
divides digital twins into three
different types
he talks about digital models or
simulations and that's where data
is exchanged manually maybe um so for
example maybe in covid we're getting
some stats each day someone's taking
those stats and then plugging them into
a model and that's a manual process then
we have digital shiddo
digital shadows which are one-way data
exchange
so the real-world item is sending data
into the platform
and finally the most complex and mature
digital twin where we have
bi-directional data exchange
so perhaps in our air con example then
we have the ability to go and control
this
aircon unit from our digital twin
now typical digital twins will give you
four main functions
they allow you to visualize the current
state of the item or process how hot's
this room right now what's the
air conditioning unit operating at
they'll probably trigger
alerts under certain conditions is that
room getting too hot
is it cooking everyone inside it will
probably allow you to
review historical data maybe how hot was
this room last year at this time and
year
and the more advanced digital twins will
allow you to simulate different
scenarios
and there's even examples of people
creating digital twins prior to creating
the actual physical product
this can save a lot of money and time in
product development
summarizing the benefits of digital
twins i think digital twins can help you
make better decisions
they can assist with maintenance and
safety they can reduce the costs of
several things
they can improve efficiencies in your
organization maybe your building you
shut off
different lights and rooms if they're
not in use and of course
making prediction and i'm going to show
you some examples of this very shortly
now our product one of our products is
focused on the
real estate market and i want to show
you a few key aspects of this
now this isn't going to play so well um
over
a stream so i encourage you if you just
look up
willow inc.com you'll find us on our
home page but i do want to show
a couple of key aspects to it so we
create complete models of these
buildings down to very fine levels of
detail
and what this enables you to do the
building manager can look at these
models
they can zoom into them down to the
level of individual pipes
and units and see where the problems are
we've got another product associated
with rail and what we're seeing here is
some details of
some rail track there allowing the
people managing these systems to quickly
find issues
where did digital twins come from in the
first place
does anyone know what this is it's a bit
of a grainy image
um but some of you folks probably are
familiar with
what this image is already now this
image here is of
apollo 13. i think even if you're not
that interested into
space a lot of people were probably
aware um of the somewhat ill-fated
apollo 13 mission
so um and apparently this was due to a
technician
originally due to a technician carrying
a
oxygen cylinder and accidentally
dropping it which would lead to
a number of events and eventually uh one
of the these oxygen cylinders
exploding apollo 13 had some problems
and the problem with this was that
obviously apollo 13 is really really far
away
from those down on earth who can go and
help apollo 13.
now one of the unique things about this
was that
prior to this mission nasa had set up 15
different simulators
of apollo 13 and the lunar module
apparently there was four computers
alone um for
needed in order to simulate um the
rocket system
now what was unique about these
simulators and i'm not going to claim a
simulator as a digital twin um they're
definitely not
is that these simulators allowed um the
controllers to specify various
parameters in order to set the state of
the system
and they could set these things up very
quickly so by taking
the real world state of what's actually
happening to apollo 13
some of those details they'd uh have on
hand and some of them they might need to
query from the crew
they were able to create a very accurate
replica of what
apollo 13 was allowing them to test
various scenarios
in order to help get these astronauts
back to work
uh back to you and
i think this is probably one of the
furthest first examples of
what could be considered a digital twin
going forwards and we have this guy um
david galentia i'm probably pronouncing
your name your name wrong
um he did a lot of work in parallel
computing and the linda language
but what we're interested in is a book
he wrote called mirror worlds
now bear in mind this is in 1991 and i'm
going to read the second paragraph for
this
and he says this mirror world you are
looking at is fed by a steady rush of
new data
pouring in through cables it is
infiltrated by your own software
creatures doing your business
and david kind of puts forward this idea
of digital twins
that we have today we have john vickers
who is widely credited for being the
first person to coin the term digital
twin
and depending on the source you look at
this was in 2002 or um
2010 um but what we really find is
this guy michael greaves who goes and
popularizes um this concept
now michael's interested in how he can
apply digital twins to the manufacturing
process
and he proposes that we can create this
digital construct
that's linked to the physical item and
that this could create a lot of
efficiencies allowing us to test
various proposals but of course digital
twins wouldn't have been popular
without several other advances so we see
all sorts of things from
the proliferation of cheap iot devices
because if it's expensive to implement
these kind of things then you know
that's a bit discouraging to actually do
it
and of course these things are dependent
on various things such as processing
improvements
comms advances even batteries because if
your
devices are running out all the time
that's no good to anyone
and then we see a heap of other things
protocol standards cloud hosting systems
to go and process this data
down to 3d modeling vr augmented reality
and so on
i think you'd even argue recently that
our least favorite coronavirus is
probably also accelerating some of the
work here
um a great example again i'd encourage
you to go to
the link here i'm going to pick out a
couple of key points
is a digital twin that's been created of
the state of uh victoria
now this digital twin kind of focuses on
a couple of aspects
it focuses on planning aspects so they
believe this is going to assist
get various building planning
applications through a lot quicker
um they look at integrating uh energy um
sources
uh into it and also for disaster
planning so you'll see how they go and
use
um flooding data uh in order to look at
how
you know what might happen um to this
location had a flood
occur so i'm just going to play that and
pick out a couple of parts
and over the next three years
so it's pretty cool some of the stuff
that's going on
with this singapore there's been a
digital singapore since 2014.
if you go look it up there's an immense
amount of details in that model
they use it for urban planning and also
again for
disaster and planning and modelling some
recent examples
these digital twins have been employed
in order to optimize
vaccination centers in order to get
people through as quick as possible
but also in a safe socially distant way
we see it used across nuclear power
solar car energy
and even in livestock farming now this
livestock farming um is particularly
interesting
in the the people who put this paper
together
they propose using facial recognition
technology
on cows in order to understand how
the cow's going at the moment and
contribute to that animal's welfare so
it's quite a
creative use of some of these things and
you can see there's a lot of different
um examples here
some of these things are quite abstract
in nature they're more concepts rather
than
um a physical device that we're
mirroring here
so um hopefully i've convinced you that
maybe this is an interesting
area and it's got a widespread use of
examples of where you could deploy this
and what i want to talk about next
is how you can go about creating digital
twins yourself
and using the azure digital twins
platform now i also think it's fairly
unique service um to azure and i haven't
come across anything
similar that's going to offer some of
the stuff i'll show you in a minute
before we get into that however azure
offers another service called
iot hub now a lot of you may be familiar
with this service
you can certainly use this with azure
digital twins if you want to
but don't feel that you have to these
are independent things
and somewhat confusingly iot hub has
this concept of device twins
this is completely different concept to
digital twins and
in iot hub world device twins it's
all to do with config and firmware
management
so let's imagine we're setting out to
create a new digital
uh twin project maybe um we want to do
something similar to our building
example that we talked about earlier on
we've got lots of devices in our
building we're getting measurements from
various different places
what do we need well at the start of it
you can think of
well we're going to need to a few things
in order to create a digital twin of
this building
one of the first things we're going to
need is the ability to go and actually
define a digital twin
um we're going to need to define what is
this air conditioning unit what are its
capabilities
what measurements can we get from it
also how are these things related
so maybe there's some kind of plumbing
system it's going to be pretty useful if
you know
which pipe's connected to which pipe and
this feeds into
this component here and so on
we're gonna need a way to go and update
the twin state because if it's not
reasonably up-to-date well
it's not that useful um we'll probably
want the ability to be able to perform
uh different queries across the digital
twins that we've set up
so for example we might want to know
which
air conditioning units are operating
above 30 degrees
because that's really quite hot and we
should go and check that out we're going
to want a way of securely integrating
with these things
and ideally maybe you've got investment
in the azure platform already
it'd be great if it's integrated with a
lot of existing azure services
so that brings us to azure digital twin
now microsoft marketing
say that azure digital twin is an
internet of things
platform that enables you to create a
digital representation of real world
things places businesses and processes
and people
but what does that actually mean well i
think we can divide the azure digital
twin platform
into five maybe five and a half main
things now
underlying all of this is a graph
database and this is going to store your
twin models
the state of your twins how they're
related but we're going to need a way of
defining them
and this is where twin schema or dtdl
comes
in now twin schema or dtl
dtdl is the equivalent of creating some
empty tables in the relational database
world
we've created our tables we've set how
they're related we've specified our
fields and their types but we haven't
actually created
any definitions of twins so we're going
to need a way of doing that
and that's where the 20 different
definitions come in now if you want to
work with any of this
the azure digital twin platform and i'm
going to call that adt now
because that's kind of a mouthful as
your digital twin platform
is we've got this rest api that we can
work with
so this means whatever language or
platform you work with
you can work with this platform but of
course it's not that convenient to go
and hand code
all of these things ourself so microsoft
also
offer um a number of sdks so we have
net go python java javascript
and you can also perform some of the
operations i'll show you through the
azure cli
let's go and actually go and create some
digital twins but prior to that let's
have a obligatory warning the demo code
now what i'm going to show you today is
not a good way to actually model
your twins and i'll tell you why shortly
it's done because it's simple
now in our scenario let's take a typical
digital twin
we've got a house and this house is
using electricity
and we want to know which houses are
using
more electricity so how are we going to
do this well the first thing we're going
to need to do
is actually come up with a way to go and
describe our digital twins so let's come
out slides and look at how we
go and do this now the way that you
actually come up
and define your digital twins is using a
language called dtdl which is
formatted as json now what i've got here
is my definition of my house object here
and you can see the type of this is
something called
a interface now interface is equivalent
to a class
in programming terminology and it has
a number of different types of fields
within it
so there's only a few of them that
you're going to need to be aware of
we're going to look at properties and
these are data fields that hold the
state of our entity these are equivalent
to classes fields
and there's relationships which link
these classes or interfaces together
in our example perhaps we go to a deeper
level
of detail and our house has rooms and a
relationship is going to allow you to
define
the rooms within the house there's also
two other types of property which i'm
not going to cover today
called telemetry and component just be
aware they're there
now our example wouldn't be too
interesting on its own so we're going to
build that up
so we're going to say we've got a house
that's got an address property
and this house also has a consumption of
electricity which we'll define as
electricity kilowatt hours
i've no idea if that's a realistic
measurement i'm not an electrician
and we're also going to create another
interface called street
and street has houses so a street could
have
zero or more houses if you will and
finally we're gonna have a district
and a district has streets let's look at
how to go and actually define this
in our dttl there so the topmost thing
that we need to care about is this id
property here and this specifies the
name
of the class there and this needs to be
unique
this has a couple of parts to it you can
see this ndc bit here
you can think of this as kind of a
namespace it needs to
prev be prefixed with dtmi prior to that
we then have the name of the object um
in this case house that's kind of
equivalent to class name
and we have this number here now this is
the version of the model that we operate
in here
so in adt i can have multiple versions
of the same thing
at the same time if i want to and then
house has
a couple of properties we have our
street
we have this new property here called
relationship
and we've basically declared the name of
the relationship here and we've also
told it
what type of objects it's pointing at
the other item i just want to call out
is this display name here
now this is used by some of the tools
i'm going to show you in a second
and can make it a bit easier to actually
go and see
what's going on with your adt models
there
now this is a very simple set of models
and once you start getting into a few
more it's quite easy to go and make a
typo
or mistake so microsoft provider tool
called
the dtdl validator which will actually
go and take all your files and go and
tell you whether something's
wrong with them so i've created a bat
file which just goes and kicks this off
and passing in
the directory and i'm going to run that
there and you can see i get this
output here that's gone and validated my
free files and everything's looking good
if i was to make a mistake say we'll
change the type there to
interface two that's probably going to
be enough
to pick up hey look something's not
quite right there
there's a bit of an issue there you
might want to take a look at it so
i'd highly recommend you use this tool
as it's going to save you
a lot of time later let's put that back
because that's going to cause us
trouble later so we'll run the validator
again
all our files look good um okay we're
ready to go and
load these into uh adt so i'm gonna
bring up
um the browser here and what this
is here is this is the azure digital
twins explorer and you can get to
this there's a little button in azure
you can click it and open digital twins
explorer and you'll get this screen here
and you can see at the moment there's
nothing in our digital twins graph
now the first thing we need to do is go
and upload our models
so i'm going to click that upload button
there and
you can see here's our three files that
i was showing you earlier
and we're going to go and load those in
so i'm going to select all of those
we'll go and open those uh it will chug
away a bit and
all being well um over on the left there
we'll then have
um these uh items uh loaded in and we
can see we've got our district our house
um and so on um i have the ability to go
and create
a twin from the ui here i can go and
click this
bottle here this button here and i can
go and look at the information on the
model
and i can have a quick check what's
going on now let's say i wanted to make
a change to some of this stuff
we talked about this version number i
could declare
version number two of the house there
and i could go back
and i could go and upload that if i
wanted to
and you'll see that we now have two
house and we can see that's the second
version there
that's going to get a bit confusing um
so let's go and get rid of that one
now at this point we've uploaded um our
structure here we've kind of got empty
tables in database terminology
and we actually need to go and create
our twin graph
now like everything in adt there's a
number of different ways um to go and do
this
the way um i'm going to go and do this
is i'm going to go and load
upload an excel file now this excel file
needs to be in quite a specific format
and microsoft specify the column order
and structure
of this so what we have here we have our
model id
that corresponds to our class name we
have the
id property now this is the unique name
of that particular digital twin instance
there
so you can see we've created several
different houses there so we've got
house
zero to seven we've got three streets
two districts
and so on now you can also set some
initial data
to define the state of um these digital
twin items here
so i'm just going to give it a simple
numeric address there
um and we'll initialize electricity
kilowatts to xero we'll set some street
names
and district names let's get rid of that
now once you're ready with that the way
to actually upload it i'm going to click
this
uploads arrow there i'm going to go and
upload this twin
setup there and then we get this preview
here
of what it's actually going to create
now this isn't created until i go and
click this save button there to start
import so i'm going to go and click
that start import there
and all being well that's going to load
in uh everything into
our digital twin graph there and we can
see we've had 13 um twins imported
and 11 relationship that's uh
imported there now you might be thinking
um that's going to get kind of
unmanageable once you've got a very
large number of items
um and i think you're right and i'd
actually unless you're doing some
initial experimentation
um i would discourage this way of doing
things the other disadvantage of
uploading stuff through the ui
um is it really doesn't give you very
many error messages so whilst i was
putting this
um when i put this example together um
you literally get something
like uh digital twin could not be
created which isn't really very helpful
in order to understand
what it is that you've done wrong so adt
offers several different ways to
actually update your and create your
digital twins you can use the azure cli
you could use one of the sdks my
preference i'd encourage you to use one
of the sdks
and you're also likely to run into a
scenario where you'll start to get
dependency issues
so you need to create certain things
before say
you need to create the house type before
creating the relationship
of a street um has houses
so that will give you that fine grain
control you need in order to
set up and go and create your twin graph
so
that's my recommendation there but it's
great for playing around for small
examples
like this so we've imported our graph
here
and you can see we've got um this
structure here uh that's
the structure that i showed you on the
slide earlier we have a district and the
district
is made up of streets and streets uh
have houses in them
now if i go over to the twin graph i'm
not seeing anything here at the moment
and that's because i haven't run this
query a bit here now
i'm going to go back to the query stuff
uh in just a minute
there's something a bit more i want to
talk to you about with
models
so we've defined our models and
relationships
and we've now got everything set up now
you might be asking it could take a bit
of time to
go and create some of these models and
especially once you get into a more
complex
domain like imagine you're trying to
model a smart city or a whole building
that's going to take a lot of time to go
and create these models
and also go and get these the modelling
around it right it's not easy this is a
fairly early days
um for how to how best to model these
things there's not a lot of
there are best practices but we're still
working out you know what some of those
things are
so one thing you can do um is you can
look at ontologies
now ontologies are a collection of
models um for a specific domain
and there's already some examples of
many different domains
so there's an example for a power grid
system already there's an example for
smart cities um all sorts of things so
you could go and take one of these
models and that's going to save you a
lot of time
from going and creating one of these
things yourself and also potentially a
lot of error
as hopefully someone's worked out some
of the issues
and the approach they've proposed is
going to work well for
a lot of people now microsoft put
forward those three main strategies for
using these models
you could potentially adopt them
entirely maybe you convert them
and you just take the bits you want
maybe you go and extend them but
all in all this can spend save you a lot
of development time when you're working
with these type of things
so i'd highly encourage you if you're
coming to a new digital chin product
go have a look what's out there first
because there's probably something that
you can at least base
your work on before you set about
creating your own models
um we've actually got our our own
building-based one
which is an extension of some of the
smart cities work there you can go and
find that on the public
github there and you'll see just how
detailed and how complex some of these
models can get
here's a visualization of the the smart
cities one
on the azure repo there
so probably your next question is okay
so we've got everything set up there
we've defined our instances of digital
twins
how do we go about actually updating
these things
well again you've got several different
uh options in you of course have
the various rest apis and sdks
and some integration with logic apps at
the moment
and then we have iot hub as well now i
put an asterix next to
iot hub as you do have to do a bit of
work yourself
you can trigger an event which creates a
function which i'm going to show you an
example of in a minute
but you do still need to do a bit of
programming yourself so
it's not completely plug and play in
terms of getting data out of it
of course you could create some polling
mechanism via the rest apis sdks
but you also have a number of different
other options
there's out the box integration with
event hub grid service bus
you can make use of events for various
things occurring from
created relationships changing telemetry
being received and so on
um let me show you a simple example of
how to
integrate this from net so
i've got a application here and
the first thing you need to do is go and
specify your digital twin
endpoint now i'm going to use the
default azure credentials to connect to
this uh in my example
because uh it's a little bit simpler now
these are created when you go and log
into
azure through something like that azure
cli and they save a bit of work and also
means i don't have to
hide credentials while showing this to
various people
so i've already logged into my
subscription video azure cli
um so that's how that's authenticated
into this now of course in the real
world
um you're not going to do that and you
have two main
options with adt for authentication if
you've got something
already running on the azure platform
you're going to want to use managed
identities
and here you basically find out
you tell azure digital twins hey i want
this
azure function that i've just created to
be part of this role in this adt graph
and have these permissions
it sounds complicated it's actually not
there's a couple of commands you have to
run i'll show you in a minute
but that uh adt to authenticate that
your server should have access
and authorize the actions that they're
taking on it now if you've got something
external
um it supports the standard oauth
protocols
you'll need to set up an application in
azure ad and so on again there's
detailed instructions on how to go about
setting this up
so back to our simple example i've got a
simple
net core cli program here
and we want to go and update the
electricity usage of house zero how do
we do that well we're going to create a
new json patch document with this line
here
i'm going to set the electricity usage
to 22
kilowatt hours however much that is and
then i'm going to apply this
to this property here electricity
kilowatts hours and we
i know if you remember we declared that
property at the
top level here so we can see the name of
that so that's mapping
through to that property there and then
we're just going to write out that it's
successfully updated
um this value so um all being well we'll
go and run that up
um and uh hopefully that will connect um
and then when we go and look at the
graph again we should see that 22
um in the value all done so that all
looks good
we'll go over to azure digital twins
explorer there
now i'm not seeing any digital twins
right now we'll go and run the query
there
and let's go and get our twin graph
there's all the
twin items that we've created there i
could go down
and many go and select house zero there
and we can see by selecting this i can
see the properties over on the right
here
and i can see that the electricity
kilowatt hours has been updated to 22
here now it's exactly the same approach
if you want to go and update this
through an azure function
for example so go into a more
complicated example and this is based on
some of the example code in the
documentation but i've cut it down a
little bit to make it a little bit more
simpler
what we're going to do is we're going to
have a net application and that's
going to send in some random values to
azure iot hub here
now when these values appear on the hub
we're going to raise an event which is
going to go and trigger
we've got this azure function that's
listening out for
this azure function is going to use some
very similar code to what i've just
shown you
in order to go and connect to azure
digital twins graph and update the state
of
um this item there and of course we
could then write a
net application website api whatever it
is
to go and read out the state of this
graph
now there is one more step we need to do
and that's that security step that i
mentioned
um earlier so we're going to use managed
identities and we're going to say
we want this as a function to have an
identity
and we then want to put the identity
and associate that with the azure
digital twins data owner role there
that's going to give it
quite a high level of permissions there
so you probably want to get a bit more
granular
but it's going to enable us to go and
update that
twin graph there so
just to show that working there
i have my simple program
which is just a console application and
this application here is just going to
send in some random
values into the iot hub
it's triggering that event which is
triggering the function function's
picking up
and then it's going updating the state
of our house so all being well we should
see this value change
i'll click off it we'll go and click on
it again and
let me close that one down and we should
hopefully see that
value updating over time so we can see
it's changing there as these events
are received and update the state of the
twin there
now one thing i should mention is it
will only hold the state
of the um the last value updated so
you're going to need to if you want
every single value of the history you're
going to need to implement that yourself
and it does kind of make sense when you
think about the immense amount of data
um that could be sent and stored on this
item you're probably going to want some
control and to choose how you
go and store and what you do with this
data
so at this point we've got everything
flowing into uh our graph
but how do we go about actually getting
data out of it
well again we have a number of different
options azure digital twin supports a
sequel like query language
now it's not sql so there's some things
you can there's many things you can do
in sql which you can't do in
adt world but some of the basic sort of
sql like statements
um it supports um there's also some new
keywords
and digital twin specific functions that
have been introduced to make your
life easier um and again you can use
this through the rest api sdks
um and uh so on so what do the queries
look like well you've got your standard
sql ones where we might do select star
from digital twins
and where we might specify a where
clause
i can go out of this and we could go
flip star from digital twins
where address 1 equals
10 and then hit the run query
i can also click this overlay results on
which is kind of an interesting thing
so that kind of filters out the other
stuff and shows you where the results of
your query sit there so that might be
quite nice for
some sort of visualization there so you
can see
it's quite easy to go and work uh work
with
uh this graph there so
coming back there's a couple of more
complex
things or functions that adt enables you
can do
you can check where where specific
properties are defined whether there are
specific types
whether there are models and of course
because this is a graph database we can
perform some more complicated things
so for example if we wanted to only
select houses within an individual
street
we have the ability to do that now it's
probably fair to say that it's not
as feature rich as some graph databases
at least right now so but it certainly
enables you to walk some of
uh these these relationships um that
you've set up and
defined here so in our scenario here if
uh we might want to select um see what's
going on
in a particular district but only see
the houses within that
now you could certainly do that for a
relational database but i think it's
maybe a bit more intuitive and
it also enables you to do some types of
queries that will be quite difficult
in standard sql once you start having
nodes linked together and wanting to
walk those nodes
and their path in terms of running costs
it's very very cheap
obviously this starts to add up if you
add on a hundred thousand
devices sending in data multiple times a
second so you'll want to do some cost
modeling
around this but right now in terms of
aud i think
this entire demo which i've been playing
with for a number of weeks um
i've spent uh one dollar 20 cents or
something and i've sent it a heap of
data
so um it's not one of those services you
need to be a bit scared of to play with
um
it's very very cheap to uh to run and
play with
now you might be wondering um when
should you go and use um
adt well i think it's probably best used
when you've got a large
number of digital twins to manage if
you've only got 10 items it's probably
more complexity than
you care about maybe you've got very
complex relationships through
between these items perhaps you'd
benefit from flexible schema
it's a bit of a pain when you've got
that standard relational database to
have to you know manage various fields
change the schema and so on
and um willow the ability to change this
schema
add to it it's very expressive that
certainly saved us a lot of development
time
and it's been very useful perhaps you
want to make use of one of these
existing ontologies that are out there
again this i really can't stress this
enough this can save you
a lot of pain and development time so if
you are working on these projects please
take a look at
what these existing ontologies uh can
give you
as its graph database we can perform uh
more complex graph queries
um and so that could be pretty useful
i'm working on a project at the moment
where we have a process for modelling
and
um it's enabled us to jump between the
different nodes in the process
move horizontally move laterally into
how these systems are grouped
and this would have been quite difficult
some of these types of queries if your
standard databases
and of course if you've got an existing
investment in the azure platform
it integrates quite nicely with many
azure services
now in terms of challenges there's a few
things i just want to raise
i think a lot of people come to iot and
digital twin and they look at it and
they think
hey this is just taking in a load of
data um
processing it and doing something with
it um and uh
i must admit i did too and it's a very
naive
approach um and you will very quickly
find out that's not the case
so when you're working with these types
of projects you have to deal with all
sorts of things like
the inherent unreliability of these
devices uh
and sensors you'll find data won't be
transmitted at the times you're
expecting
batteries will run out people will
vandalize your devices
there's all sorts of different problems
to work with here
in terms of digital twins depending on
your use case
it's quite important your digital twin
is an accurate reflection
of what's happening in the the real
physical world and of course there's a
delay from sending this data processing
it
and reflecting it in your digital
representation and that's gonna be
something that you're going to have to
deal with so you're going to need to
be able to digest that data very quickly
it can be hard and expensive to add
these
digital version to an existing system or
implementation and it's probably worth
noting that some of the
things that these are employed in as
well will very likely outlive
the software that you write and that's
kind of unusual so
hopefully we'd expect a building to last
maybe at least 50 100
probably more years i can't think of
many software
um examples where that's that's been
around that length of time
the modeling of these things is
difficult and it's evolving i think you
can mitigate that to some extent
by working with ontologies
interoperability and standards still
developing especially in the iot
world there's a number of pain points
there
and of course if you're creating a
digital representation of something you
also need to look at the privacy and
confidentially
confidentiality aspects of that as it
could reveal quite a lot of information
about people and systems um
wrapping things up digital twins are a
virtual representation of a real-world
object or process
they bring together data in an easy to
understand and actionable form
i think they offer several advantages
around making better decisions
analysis monitoring diagnostics
diagnostics
efficiency and ultimately the ability to
even make
predictions the azure digital twins
platform consists of a number of
components a graph database
a language for describing the twins apis
and sdks
and if you take one thing away from this
once you could implement all this stuff
yourself
i really think if adt can save you a lot
of time
and pain from doing this um finally
quick plug for my company
if this world of digital twins sounds
interesting to you
and we're looking for a number of folks
please reach out to me if you've got any
questions tell them i sent you
and in terms of further reading there's
a great summary on an academic article
here if you want to get more into the
history of it
if you're wondering how our platform
works and want to take a deep dive into
the
architecture of that please consult this
link here and we've got a great session
with microsoft and some of my willow
colleagues will explain in detail
um some of the projects and how we've
implemented this
thank you very much that's awesome alex
phew
well there is a question and it's asked
by this amazing guy called last clint
um there was actually that guy
there was so much information in this
session and i have like one
main question i think is sort of like
holy moly where do i even start like is
there a simple
example where you can sort of just go
yeah if this looks of interest to you
and you want to have a play with it
maybe you've got
a raspberry pi and some iot devices in
your own house you want to play with it
um what i do first of all is i'd head
over to the microsoft azure digital twin
site
there's extensive documentation it's
well written
there's multiple examples some of the
examples i've showed you there are based
on some of the
microsoft stuff it's really very easy to
get started with
and play with this stuff so you can use
a raspberry pi
oh absolutely like if you if you want to
integrate anything
um into this you'll have to write code
to either send it
into adt world or maybe you send it
via azure iot hub um and then you'll
have to write the the bits that link
those two things together
but sure um you could that's what
they're here
so that's cool that's wow that was a lot
of information
um i just i like the graphical part of
it it just appeals to me
it's not all code right you can see
what's actually going on it does and it
does this cool
animation where it goes and arranges
your yeah yeah as well
and especially on a more complex setup
like my example is fairly trivial i
think there's what 10
10 or so items there once you get into
hundreds or thousands
you get kind of a spectacular graph and
it's quite easy to sort of navigate
between these things
that's awesome well thank you so much
alex for being part of ndc melbourne
thank you that was uh very informative
and if you want to know more about this
reach out to alex directly or put it in
the youtube chat or wherever else you
can find them so